über russische kriegsrhetorik und
propaganda wollen wir jetzt sprechen und
zwar mit dem militärexperten oberst ag
wolfgang richter von der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik guten abend
herr richter warum hat lavrov das jetzt
gesagt dass er die ukrainische regierung
stürzen will warum hat er das jetzt
gesagt und warum sagt das überhaupt
er hat zunächst einmal das so wir
festhalten dass wir aus moskau schon
sehr unterschiedliche vorstellungen über
die kriegsziele gehört haben jahrelang
haben wir über die nato erweiterung
diskutiert früher gab es dazu sogar
verträge über die rüstungskontrolle die
letzten vorschläge vom dezember vertrags
vorschläge haben ja das widergespiegelt
und dann haben wir seit dem letzten jahr
etwa auch seit dieser im sommer seit
dieser zeit wird man genau ein jahr ist
es her die vorstellungen von putin
gesehen dass es eben eine historische
der historische analyse versucht er sagt
die beiden völker gehören zusammen waren
früher gehört das alles zu zahlreich war
das wäre also letztlich dann ein anderes
motiv als das sicherheitspolitische
darin das ist ja eher eine imperiales
dass ich daher überlegt und das dritte
motiv war dann eben etwas bescheidener
nämlich der schutz der bevölkerung
die aus russischer sicht russland oder
russland affin ist im don was das gilt
sicher auch dann aus russischer sicht
für den süden wir haben also ganz
unterschiedlicher vorstellungen was die
kriegsziele sind sie scheinen sich im
laufe der zeit auch mit dem verlauf der
militärischen ereignisse verändert zu
haben aber natürlich fragt man sich
warum sagt ja dass genau jetzt und warum
sagt der sg in kairo und ich glaube das
muss man eine ordnung wenn man muss
nicht nach kairo van dam ein solches
kriegsziel zu verkünden so lange es ging
russland im grunde genommen darum die
internationale blockade die der westen
die ausgeworfen hat gegen russland zu
besprechen dazu nach der ausland zu
weisen er beginnt natürlich bei einem
afrikanischen staat der den
großen nahesteht oder der sowjetunion
dann gibt und bezieht das bezog früher
sowjetische waffen jetzt immer mehr
russischer waffen und vor allem in
ägypten der hauptempfänger des getreides
das event blockiert ist also es gibt
viele gründe warum man ausgerechnet in
kairo beginnt und dann von dort aus so
eine stellungnahme abgibt was aber auch
zu sagen ist in militärische lage gibt
es ja im grunde genommen gar nicht her
dass weit gesteckte maximal kriegsziel
denn de facto ist es ja so wie wir
gerade im letzten beitrag auch gehört
haben dass die fortschritte im donbass
relativ langsam sind kleine schritte
lokale überlegenheit der artillerie aber
dann doch ein langsames durchbohren fast
schon millimeterweise während in carson
im westen die ukraine nun eine
gegenoffensive vorbereiten die
allerdings im moment auch nicht recht
vorankommt also ich sehe hier eher eine
balance der möglichkeiten und
wahrscheinlich wird am ende
entscheidend sein wer über die größeren
ressourcen verfügt gegen eine solche
materialschlacht hinein mehr vorkam
luzerner schreibt dazu auf youtube
immerhin sind die russen jetzt mal
ehrlich hat ja lange genug gedauert herr
richter da sind sie wieder der richter
lassen sie uns aber dieses szenario
jetzt mal kurz durch reden weil
unabhängig von den kämpfen an der front
ist es ja so dass wenn es russland
gelingen würde ein attentat auf den
ukrainischen präsidenten zu verüben und
dieser das nicht überleben würde was
würde das mit der kampfmoral der
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer die ja
wirklich so beachtlich ist in den
letzten monaten was würde es mit denen
machen ja zunächst mal sind wir
natürlich hier im bereich der
spekulation wir müssen festhalten dass
ein versuch ja schon im märz gemacht
worden ist von norden her kiew 1
annehmen sozusagen in streit ich habe
das gefühl dass hier die russische armee
eigentlich opfer selbst narrativ des
präsidenten geworden dass dann wenn man
glaubt dass die ukraine keine
homogenität aufweisen keine nationale
identität und lässt dich die russischen
truppen als befreier begrüßen werden
dann macht man natürlich auch
militärische fehler man bereitet sich
nicht taktisch und logistisch gut vor
man glaubt dann im handstreich nach kiew
rhein fahren zu können und erlebt dann
ein weiterer und das ist genau dort
passiert hier was muss man sich mit
großen verlusten zurückziehen oder
dieses szenario können wir schon mal
vom tisch ja ich glaube auch nicht dass
das im moment eine realistische
alternative ist zu glauben man kann ein
solches szenario wiederholen
gutachten karte darüber mag man
spekulieren aber ich glaube das ist eher
unwahrscheinlich
vor allem müssen wir sehen dass die
ukraine große sicherheitsmaßnahmen um
den präsidenten herum getroffen haben
ich glaube eher dass die russen darauf
anspielen dass sich die situation von
2014 wiederholen könnte wo noch große
teile gerade im süden und osten der
bevölkerung sich als russland auf ihn
gezeigt haben keine der ukrainischen
flotte damals vor allem sind
übergelaufen zur russischen armee hier
der schwarzmeerflotte und
wieder stand die verteidigung gute dann
noch freiwillig das hat sich natürlich
erheblich geändert das hat offenbar
russland nicht so wahrgenommen
man nimmt hier die minderheit die ist
sicherlich noch gibt man sieht es ja
auch am donnerstag mit 35.000
armeeangehörigen die auf der anderen
seite stehen man nimmt diese
bürgerkriegssituation
in einer anderen weise war als wir das
tun dann verwechselte minderheit und
mehrheit offenbar und das führt zu
diesen fehleinschätzungen das ändert
aber nichts an der tatsächliche
militärischen lage die ressourcen frage
ist längst nicht gelöst natürlich kann
russland auch auf ressourcen
zurückgreifen die ukraine ist abhängig
von westlichen lieferung
lassen es uns noch mal kurz bei diesem
thema psychologische kriegsführung
bleiben ihre kollegin margarete klein
hat da letzte woche bei uns im stream
bei zdf heute live darüber gesprochen
daher kurz rein was wir in bezug auf
westliche staaten zu erwarten haben ist
sicherlich nutzung herbst hinein eine
viel stärkere sogenannte psychologische
kriegsführung operation oder den versuch
durch propaganda und desinformation eben
die innenpolitische debatte zu drehen
denn für putin ist eine schwäche
westlicher staaten diejenigen
dass die dortigen politiker auf die
öffentliche meinung rücksicht nehmen
müssen und deswegen versucht man ganz
gezielt die öffentliche meinung zu
beeinflussen damit von dort aus druck
auf die führungen ausgeübt wird dass man
sagt na ja es hat eigentlich gar keinen
sinn die ukraine zu unterstützen ein
schlechter waffenstillstand sei besser
als die fortsetzung des krieges was aber
letztendlich nur russische gebiete und
russische gewinne konsolidieren würde
er recht er ist eine solche ankündigung
die ukrainische regierung stürzen zu
wollen auch eine ganz klare botschaft an
den westen
also ich glaube dass du im westen nicht
verfangen das ist ja eher eine drohung
entweder mit einem attentat was ich habe
jetzt wieder gemacht wahrscheinlich
halte zumal es ja gar keine
innenpolitische auswirkung hätte denn es
gibt genügend kräfte der ukraine die
diesen krieg diese verteidigung
weiterführen werden aber ich denke wenn
es um eine solche hilfe wie er sagt geht
dann wird sich das ukrainische volk von
einer solchen regierung befreit dann
kann es nicht nur militärische operation
handeln und hier sehe ich noch keine
entsprechenden erfolgsaussichten ich
glaube dass im moment auf allen seiten
maximal ziele formuliert werden und ich
glaube keiner tut gut daran im westen
jetzt über so etwas wie eine
kapitulation streamen zu reden natürlich
ist das gar nicht mehr gilt auf der
anderen seite wird es aber in frieden am
ende auch nur geben wenn man letztlich
dann doch verhandelt aber das heißt ja
dass alle von ihren maximal ziehen
abweichen müssen ein solcher frieden
kann ja nur unterhalb von maximal zielen
erfolgen wie das bisher die historische
erfahrung ist und das darf weder
kapitulation seien noch überzeugender
forderungen einer total ruiniert der
russischen armee etwa oder der
russischen wirtschaft denn wir sehen ja
auf allen möglichen ebenen auf der
wirtschaft gegenüber auf der
militärischen dass man auf allen seiten
versuchte solchen maximalforderungen
etwas entgegenzusetzen und das läuft er
dann auf eine materialschlacht hinaus
und man fragt man sich wer kann
eigentlich mehr ressourcen aufbringen
über die ressourcen entsprechen wir
gleich noch es gibt eine frage auf
youtube was die einschätzung ist ob der
krieg so lange laufen wird bis die ganze
ukraine eingenommen ist oder ob den
russen ein gewisser teil reichen wird
das ist eine frage an welchen
wahrscheinlich
wir schauen in die glasbrücke her wir
sind beim spekulieren am ende wird auch
in russland oder die russische führung
natürlich zu einem schluss kommen müssen
denn dann abwägt was denn noch tragbar
ist weitere hohe militärische verluste
in kauf zu nehmen oder an irgendeinem
punkt zu sagen das war es jetzt putin
ist jan frey einen sieg zu erklären wenn
er es für richtig hält weil wir ja
unterschiedliche negative bereits gehört
hat das geht wenn ich mal an die
äußerungen von präsident selensky vom
märz anknüpfen da hat er drei vorschläge
gemacht erstens verzicht auf den
nato-beitritt zweiten sonderstatus für
den bass der zwischen den präsidenten
verhandelt wird und drittens einen
sonderstatus fällt die crème bia der
arbeit zunächst einmal für 15 jahre
verschoben wird so dass man das dann
noch mal neu beginnen kann bis dahin so
etwas wie eine de facto anerkennung der
russischen kontrolle nicht gehe also
nicht rechtlich das waren ja schon sehr
weitreichende vorschläge und sind alle
seiten offenbar von solchen vorschlägen
abgeglichen haben maximal ziele gesetzt
ich glaube realismus bedeutet dass man
unterhalb der maximal ziele am ende zu
einem nüchternen ergebnis kommen muss
und das wird wahrscheinlich doch
irgendwo dort liegen wo sie lenski
bereits ende märz seine vorschläge
gemacht hat topolino hat noch eine frage
wird das ukrainische staatsgebiet dann
einfach russisch im falle eines putsches
gegen selensky
das glaube ich eher nicht denn wir haben
ja nicht nur eine figur die in der
ukraine den widerstand prägt sondern man
muss ja noch deutlich sehen dass selen
cigs vorschläge die ja schon sehr
weitreichend waren auch auf ihren
politischen widerstand gestoßen sind
weil das gefühl der nationalen identität
ist natürlich im laufe der acht jahre
seit der kollektion erheblich
angestiegen die ukraine hatte noch nie
so eine wie der identität oder nationale
einheit gehabt wie das jetzt der fall
ist nachdem russland angegriffen hat wir
können sogar vielleicht zynisch
feststellen so im gegensatz zu dem
negativ von putin ist putin hat dazu
beigetragen
dass die identität der ukrainische
nation nun wird deutlich angestiegen ist
dass es nicht nur den besten betrifft
wie das vielleicht historisch oder
traditionell war sondern jetzt bis weit
in den osten hinein reicht auch die
russischsprachige bevölkerung betrifft
und das heißt der widerstand wird nicht
nur an seelands gelegen es gibt genügend
führungsfiguren in der ukraine um das
weiter zu tragen ich behaupte sogar eine
widerstandswillen würde auch dann nicht
brechen wenn kiew gekommen ist lassen
sie uns zum schluss noch kurz darüber
sprechen wie die ukraine zurzeit
militärisch gerüstet ist heute sind ja
die ersten drei flugabwehr panzer vom
typ g parteien getroffen auf diese
panzer der bundeswehr hatte das land
schon lange gewartet und heute sind sie
eben angekommen zusammen mit 10 tausend
schuss munition
die
bundesregierung hatte ende april 30
ausgemusterte exemplare versprochen
diese mussten aber noch instand gesetzt
werden eigentlich sollten sie bis mitte
juli schon da sein insgesamt 15 herr
richter inwiefern verbessert dass nun
die militärische situation für das
ukrainische militär
ja da muss man zunächst einmal die
westlichen waffenlieferungen in den
kontext sehen werden wir sehen was die
nato staaten geliefert haben also allen
voran natürlich erstmal polen mit 240 t
72 panzern auch viele andere staaten um
die amerikaner mit sehr vielen habitzl
auch deutschland hat sich mit gemeinsam
mit holland hier eingeleitet mit zehn
modellen panzer haben jetzt um 2000
frankreich und großbritannien dagegen
etwa auf der gleichen ebene und wenn man
das alles zusammenfasst dann kommen wir
auf schwere waffen die in die hunderte
gehen also wir sind bei etwa 250
westlichen putzen dazu kommen eine ganze
reihe von
westlicher bauart
die kampfpanzer habe ich genannt und in
diesem rahmen reizt dich jetzt ein was
wir jetzt sehen diese gepard lieferungen
das ist ja wohl unter der erste tranche
der ersten szene von 15 weitere 15
sollen folgen und der gepard als solcher
hat natürlich eine hohe feuerkraft er
ist eigentlich ein fleck panzer also ein
flugabwehr panzer der in der lage ist
die trockene in der bewegung gegen
luftangriffe aus dem niedrigen höhen zu
schützen sprechen als dagegen niedrig
fliegender jagdflugzeuge jagdbomber und
kampfhubschrauber er hat aber auch eine
feuerkraft gegen bodenziele und die ist
ganz erheblich das heißt er wird schon
dazu beitragen dass die feuerkraft
erheblich wenn er verstärkt wird aber
man muss das in diesem kontext einbauen
denn die zahl als solche ist ja zunächst
einmal geringer und wird für sich
natürlich jetzt kein game changer sein
wie man das überhaupt nicht bei
einzelnen waffensystemen sagen kann das
ist die das ist die taktischen regel
ganz dreht denn am ende kommt es darauf
an wie man seine waffen
vernünftig aufeinander abgestimmt
einsetzen und dass man im westen
taktischen erfolg hat das haben sie
jetzt gut eingeordnet denn für ricoh hat
uns auf youtube geschrieben das ist doch
lächerlich wenig oder wie sie sagen im
gesamtzusammenhang sieht das dann
natürlich etwas anders ausschauen wir
noch mal auf die deutschen
waffenlieferungen es gibt ja probleme
mit dem sogenannten ringtausch denn
ursprünglich war geplant das östliche
nato partner wie polen und tschechien
ältere panzer sowjetischer bauart in die
ukraine liefern das ist zwar geschehen
nur hat deutschland diese partnerländer
dafür noch nicht wie bisher vereinbart
war mit moderneren leopard-panzern
ausgestattet und jetzt werden die
stimmen in der bundesregierung lauter
solche panzer eben nicht über umwege
sondern direkt an die ukraine zu liefern
was würden sie sagen ringtausch oder
direktlieferung er zu beginn der
erstklässler der inkas immer das
angesagte weil es einfach schneller geht
weil man für einen ringtausch die
gleichen systeme verwenden kann die man
direkt in die ukraine geschickt die dort
im einsatz sind also diese t-72
beispielsweise dafür braucht man nicht
ausbilden und hat die munition und auch
keine ersatz
hier kann man übernehmen und damit
kämpfen das wird aber jetzt allmählich
an das ende kommen denn diese waffen
ströme sind erschöpft und auch die
verluste der ukraine nehmen zu das wird
man daran gehen irgendwann mal auch auf
westliches gerät umzuschalten das ist
bei den hobbits geschehen die artillerie
stellt im moment um auf festliches
systeme was die kampfpanzer betrifft
betrifft das hat aber auch eine
politische dimension bevor ich mal auf
das technische komme denn bisher hat
noch kein staat auch die usa nicht
kampfpanzer westlicher bauart in die
ukraine geliefert wenn dann wäre das
kein alleingang großstadt das würde man
dann nur zusammen und wir den usa
großbritannien und frankreich
wie sehr hat keiner das geliefert ich
sage nicht dass das eine rote linie ist
den überschritten werden kann aber es
macht ja schon ein unterschied ob ein
kampfpanzer gegen eine typisch deutsche
signatur hat ein russischer truppen über
die grenzen treibt
und ganz im alleingang oder ob es jetzt
um eine katze konzipiert der westliche
aktion geht also das ist nun mal die
politische hatte die technische seite
jetzt aber eine andere die bundeswehr
verfügt nicht über ausreichend
kampfpanzer in den aktiven verbänden es
gibt so viele kampf panzerbataillone die
letztlich nur über die hälfte ihres
bestands verfügung die bundeswehr hat
aber die verpflichtung jetzt die
bündnisverteidigung vorzubereiten und
schrittweise eine bis 2025 eine
panzerdivision auch zustand um die
ostflanke der nato zu schützen das ist
eine verpflichtung die in madrid
getroffen worden ist denn man sich nicht
entziehen kann dafür gibt es auch nicht
nur die allgemeine erhöhung des
verteidigungshaushalts sondern auch
dieses sondervermögen von 100 milliarden
und das muss möglichst schnell jetzt
passieren dass dir tut mir ja nicht voll
ausgestattet ist dann auch voll
ausgestattet wird und es geht nicht
anders geht dann am ende auch munition
ich glaube das ist sogar noch die uhr
ist der größte engpass denn die
westliche industrie vor allem die
deutsche industrie ist ja auch eine
kriegsproduktion im moment nicht
eingestellt ich sehe damit noch keinen
umsteuern auf kriegsproduktion aber ich
sehe das ist ein dilemma gibt nämlich
die eigene verteidigung zu stärken was
er eine verpflichtung ist der nato und
der bundesregierung und zum anderen aus
den depots
das thema älterer bauart herauszuholen
die natürliche ressourcen verschlingen
bis sie dann einsatzbereit gemacht
werden und dafür ersatzteile zu finden
und die munition etc noch auszubilden
also das muss schon gegeneinander
abgewogen werden und einfach zum regal
zu gehen und die dinge abzuholen das
wäre dann doch zu einfach jetzt noch
eine meinung reingekommen von anna
surena auf youtube da würde ich gerne
wissen wie ihre antwort ist russland
droht übrigens nicht mit einem regime
change in kiew es bietet lediglich seine
unterstützung an das ist etwas ganz
anderes was würden sie an antworten
na ja das ist die lektion von darauf
gewesen das ist mir auch aufgefallen
dass er sagt wir helfen dem burgenland
ab 3 aber das sind natürlich
formulierungen die das ganze vielleicht
etwas abfedern sollen aber an der essenz
der aussage glaube ich ist ja nichts
zurück nicht zu rütteln das war nämlich
schon glaubt auf der ebenfalls lawrow
hat das so ausgeprägt dass man in der
lage wäre die virus die ukrainische
opposition so zu stärken dass sie zu
einem solchen putscht wenn man das denn
so lernen wir in der lage ist ohne dass
russische truppen mit vorstössen müssten
das sehe ich als totale illusion an
obwohl ich nicht bestreitet dass das
natürlich russland affine
bevölkerungsteile gibt auf der krim
orient und was vielleicht noch im süden
wo die ukraine ja selber darum ringen um
festzustellen wie kann es zu einer
solchen kooperation kommen dass im süden
gebiete eingenommen werden von
russischen truppen ohne großen
widerstand ohne dass brücken gesprengt
werden übrigens dafür ist nicht der spd
verantwortlich für wolken sprengungen
ist die armee verantwortlich und noch
eine letzte frage für heute von jens
heppner auf youtube herr richter müssen
wir wirklich zu sehen wenn russland das
durchzieht
ich vermute er meint wenn russland die
ukraine völlig unter kontrolle nehmen
will
nun zu sehen das kann man ja nichts
sagen also werden sie sich anschauen was
westliche regierungschefs miteinander
vereinbart haben dann kann man sagen das
ist ja eine doppelstrategie gibt und
zwar einerseits die militärische und
finanzielle und wirtschaftliche hilfe
für die ukraine
auf der anderen seite aber auch den
versuch russland so zu isolieren dass
die russische wirtschaft in die knie
geht der zweite teil der strategie die
inhaltlich jetzt schon für gescheitert
offen gesagt weil es gelingt nicht den
globalen süden davon zu überzeugen dass
die parteien nehmen sollen in einem
neuen ost west konflikt der aus sicht
des globalen südens in erster linie im
konflikt zwischen nördlichem staaten ist
und das heißt vor allen dingen konflikt
zwischen ehemaligen kolonialmächten das
heißt jeder hat man einen ganz anderen
blick auf die dinge und selbst starten
die sich selbst als demokratisch sehen
wir haben es beim g7-gipfel erlebt
werden diese diese block konfrontation
nicht wollen und mich daran teilnehmen
das ist auch die frage ob das
langfristig im interesse der
internationalen ordnung ist und die un
dann so spaltet ich glaube eher dass es
darum gehen muss die ukraine zu
befähigen ein widerstand zu leistende
ihre verhandlungsposition verbessern so
dass sie am ende ihre souveränität
wahren können aber der dritte aspekt
einer strategie die arbeit bisher
vermisst es muss auch den versuch geben
vernünftige verhandlungslösung
vorzuschlagen die etwa dort liegen
könnten valencias vorschlag ja schon im
märz lag hier glaube ich kann man noch
mehr tun um auch diese möglichkeit einer
diplomatischen lösung immer wieder ins
auge zu fassen wenn sie heute vielleicht
nicht machbar es aber wenn der
erschöpfungszustand zunimmt dann glaube
ich dann wird es darauf hinauslaufen